[Musica]
in passato all'inizio delle scuole
elementari
se non si imparava correttamente e
velocemente a leggere a scrivere si
veniva etichettati come pigri e
svogliati se non addirittura come
stupidi spesso questi bambini non
riuscivano a terminare i propri studi e
talvolta nemmeno le scuole dell'obbligo
fino a pochi anni fa erano meno noti e
difficilmente diagnosticabili i dsa
ovvero i disturbi specifici
d'apprendimento
che possono implicare svariate e
talvolta multiple neuro diversità che
possono risultare evidente o meno a
occhi esterni a seconda della tipologia
specifica
tali dsa riguardano la lettura la
scrittura
l'elaborazione delle operazioni
matematiche
lo studio ai processi mnemonici e in
generale riguardano anche la percezione
del mondo esterno
inoltre di solito riguardano individui
di intelligenza medio alta
quest'ultima una caratteristica necessià
le affinché la diagnosi di dsa
venga confermata ma nonostante questo al
giorno d'oggi
qualsiasi concetto relativo al diverso
nell'immaginario comune assume una
connotazione negativa in quanto viene
percepito come qualcosa di non standard
che diverge dalla massa quando invece in
un mondo dove tutto è omologato sono
proprio elementi che funzionano e
ragionano in maniera differente quelle
che possono fornire elementi davvero
innovativi punti di vista alternativi e
interessanti in merito ad esempio la
capacità di prova il solving e altri
aspetti essenziali della vita
pur essendo al giorno d'oggi ben note
tutte le capacità e potenzialità dei ds
a oltre che documentate da molteplici
autorevoli studi purtroppo si continuano
a pensare per mera ignoranza
che questo tipo di di libri siano
intellettualmente meno dotati sebbene
sia sufficiente effettuare una semplice
ricerca su google per avere l'idea di
tutte le menti illustri con dsa che
hanno cambiato il mondo giusto per
citare un esempio nel 2017 dubbio c'e un
professore all'università di losanna
dichiaratamente dislessico ha vinto il
premio nobel per la chimica
oggi sono qui per parlarvi le dsa
secondo la mia esperienza attualmente
sono una dottoranda all'estero ma in
passato sono stata studentessa presso la
sapienza
mi sono laureata alla magistrale in
informatica con 110 e lode e con un anno
di anticipo finendo quindi in un solo
anno mentre lavoravo presso la sa piazza
appunto durante il periodo universitario
ho avuto modo di conoscere molti ragazzi
che avevano differenti diagnosi di dsa
sin da bambina
io ad esempio sono sempre stata
particolare ad esempio scrivevo e
leggevo anche al contrario non c'era
alcuna differenza per me avevo un
alfabeto tutto mio impiegato qualche
secondo a distinguere la destra dalla
sinistra
insomma mi accorgevo io stessa di essere
molto diversa da tutti gli altri la cosa
non mi dispiaceva ma al tempo stesso mi
ha sempre reso molto introspettiva
riflettevo tantissimo per essere una
semplice bambina e non capivo io stessa
come mai nessun altro notasse tutti i
dettagli e gli elementi che io riuscivo
invece a percepire in ogni istante era
come essere circondata da persone che
erano cieche e sorde che però
anatomicamente non lo erano oppure non
capivo come mai per me le lettere i
numeri avessero automaticamente suoni
colori odori specifici oppure ancora
perché ricollegandomi a queste inusuali
e involontari associazioni
automaticamente riuscissi a ricordare
molto più facilmente concetti complessi
ho appreso in un tempo remoto rispetto
all'utilizzo della memoria tradizionale
basata solamente sul mero ripetere ad
alta voce una poesia ad esempio
alla fine ho scoperto in età adulta
che il motivo di tutto questo dipendeva
dal fatto che io stessa avevo una forma
di dsa e ricevere questa informazione
non ha cambiato il mio modo di essere
il mio impegno in tutto ciò che mi ha
sempre appassionato è sempre stato lo
stesso avevo già raggiunto infatti in
passato dei traguardi che mi ero
prefissata ricevere questa notizia
infatti in qualche modo mi ha acceso la
consapevolezza che potevo fare
addirittura molto di più è infatti tutto
ciò per me è stata come un'opportunità
per sfidare e superare i miei limiti
visto che quello che avrei voluto
cercare di fare era laurearmi non solo
anno mentre lavoravo cosa che mi era
stata detta impossibile per laurearsi
con un anno in anticipo alla sapienza
occorreva avere la media superiore a 29
a 20 nito tutti gli esami e la tesi
oltre aver avviato e concluso tutta una
lunga serie di pratiche burocratiche in
specifiche tempistiche realizzare questo
obiettivo non è stato semplice per
diverse ragioni tra cui il fatto di
avere pochi appelli considerati tutti
gli esami da dover sostenere in maniera
necessariamente impeccabile o quasi
il lavoro e altri laboratori
universitari che frequentavo per
interesse personale
il mio lavoro consisteva nell'essere la
referente di una società americana che
produce software ampiamente utilizzati
in ambito accademico industriale
il mio compito era quello di organizzare
corsi per gli studenti iscritti in
discipline stand per insegnargli a
utilizzare questi software e fornirgli
anche un'adeguata preparazione qualora
volessero sostenere l'esame per la
certificazione ufficiale che in alcuni
dipartimenti era convalidata in cfu
un altro dei miei compiti era fornire
attività di supporto alla docenza in
forma non continuativa questo significa
che a seconda delle richieste dei
docenti ti dovevo preparare delle slits
degli esercizi svolgere delle elezioni
in vari dipartimenti tra cui ingegneria
dei trasporti
informatica automatica
chimica economia e talvolta ciò
implicava che io dovessi studiare
argomenti che non facevano parte del mio
corso di laurea o comunque ripassarli
approfonditamente per cui si trattava di
ulteriore tempo che veniva sottratto
alla preparazione dei miei esami
grazie a questa esperienza ho avuto
l'opportunità di approfondire vari
argomenti in ambito scientifico
ed ho sempre svolto con massima
diligenza ogni compito stando almeno a
tutti i feedback che ho ricevuto in
forma anonima
al termine di ogni evento e con assoluta
passione ed è stata proprio quest'ultima
la chiave che mi ha dato la forza di
proseguire per cercare di ultimare
quanto mi ero prefissata sebbene le mie
energie fossero pressoché assenti
questo per dire che contrariamente a
quanti ancora possono ancora pensare
avere una mente che funziona in modo
diverso
non fate dsa delle persone inadatte a
svolgere mansioni che implicano lo
studio in quanto il concetto stesso di
diverso non implica né migliore né
peggiore
ma solamente differente affettatutto che
il risultato finale lo stesso o della
medesima qualità tra l'idea di
differenza non dovrebbe essere
considerato quanto meno esistere
proprio nel contesto lavorativo mi è
capitato che alcuni dei ragazzi che
seguivano i miei corsi mi confidassero
spontaneamente di avere delle diagnosi
di dsa e di non averlo dichiarato
amministrativamente per timore poi di
essere considerati
diversamente intelligenti dai propri
colleghi avevano paura di risultare
stupidi o di subire battute o di essere
accusati di aver avuto le cose
facilitate per così dire altri ancora
avevano come unico obiettivo il
raggiungimento del 18 in quanto secondo
la loro opinione
in ogni caso non avrebbero potuto ad
aspirare di meglio a causa della loro
condizione è che non erano nemmeno certi
se un giorno sarebbero
usciti a ultimare il proprio percorso
universitario
indubbiamente accettare o meno voti di
questo tipo è una scelta legittimissima
che può derivare da svariate situazione
considerazioni personali ma che venga
fatta solamente perché si ritiene di non
poter avere alcuna alternativa e ci si
rassegna a quanto ci è stato detto è
veramente amareggiante è sconfortante
notare quanto al giorno d'oggi non si
riesca a fatto a percepire che proprio
in un mondo come questo dove tutto è
molto grato standardizzato in qualche
modo reso uguale a qualcosa che già
esiste
sono proprio elementi che lavorano in
modo differente quelle che possono
davvero apportare autentica innovazione
sicuramente non è mai semplice ultimare
qualsiasi percorso universitario e
alcune persone potrebbero avere maggiori
difficoltà rispetto ad altre ma la
prospettiva di attraversare un percorso
possibilmente più arduo non dovrebbe
essere un pretesto per arrendersi o per
impegnarsi ancora di più nel trovare
soluzioni efficaci e alternative per
superarle nel modo più brillante
possibile tenendo fede ai propri sogni
alle proprie ambizioni e soprattutto a
se stessi ho vissuto molti momenti in
cui ho pensato seriamente di arrendermi
per stanchezza eccessivo stress e
probabilità di riuscita prossima allo
zero per non parlare poi del periodo
infatti a causa del covip il mondo si
stava letteralmente fermando
alla fine però ho deciso di non
arrendermi anche perché nei giorni in
cui avevo deciso di arrendermi il mio
obiettivo rimaneva sempre lo stesso
rimaneva nel background della mia mente
sebbene mi sentissi più serena all'idea
di non star più perseguendo un obiettivo
ritenuto difficilmente realizzabile esso
era sempre nella mia mente e quindi ho
deciso di non arrendermi
quell'impossibile mi stava troppo
stretto tutti mi avevano detto che non
ce l'avrei fatta
ma non gli ho mai ascoltati e ne sono
felice
la vera essenza di ogni individuo la si
vede dalle proprie azioni
quando scegli che vuoi essere e io ho
scelto di essere la donna
che corre rischi che supera tutte le
paure per cercare di raggiungere i
propri obiettivi e così ho fatto la
fortuna sicuramente ha un ruolo non
indifferente nella vite può aiutare ma
non potrà mai sostituire l'azione ci
tenevo a precisare che ho deciso di
raccontare la mia storia non con
l'intento di portare alla vostra
attenzione un traguardo da emulare ma
come mero esempio per dimostrare con la
mia testimonianza che con determinazione
e coraggio è possibile perseguire
qualsiasi tipo di obiettivo persino
quelli che sono ritenuti impossibili e
più è sufficiente avere solamente
curiosità per esplorare a fondo tutti i
percorsi che la propria esistenza può
offrire un autentico amore per se stessi
e per i propri sogni qualsiasi essi
siano e che l'accontentarsi deve
dipendere solamente da una scelta
consapevole e non donò qualsiasi
condizione grazie a tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]